today on the matte wall show yelp has
introduced a new feature that will
tag and label any business that's
accused of racist behavior
what could possibly go wrong well lots
of things we'll talk about those things
today also five
five headlines including nancy pelosi
invoking the 25th amendment to remove
donald trump
from office and mel gibson starring in a
film about an alcoholic santa claus
who's being hunted by a hitman the oscar
buzz has
already started on this movie actually
the leftists are very upset about the
movie because it involves mel gibson and
that's kind of funny too so
we'll talk about that and today in a
very serious and emotional daily
cancellation i will be canceling the
people who've been cyberbullying me
over the past day you're never going to
guess why they're cyberbullying me but
they're going to get canceled
all of that on the way but first let's
talk about ventura watches you know
there's nothing better than a high
quality watch
really has the ability to elevate any
outfit you're wearing it's classy it's
classic
and you just feel good in a ventura
watch no big time price tag
their promise to you is simple solid
well-made products you're gonna enjoy
wearing
what i love about ventura watches
personally is that they've got great
looking watches
that look and feel expensive because
they're so well made
but the watches are affordable not cheap
you don't want a cheap watch you want an
affordable watch and there is a
difference and you can experience that
difference
and all the advantages of the chair
watch is with 20
off everything on their website right
now vincero has styles for men and women
as well as
accessories all made with the same
incredible quality
as their watches visit ventura
venturawatches.comwalsh
and then when you purchase use discount
walsh it's going to be automatically
applied at checkout it's that easy to
shop pinchero
they're shipping all orders directly
from their local us distributors
and they're delivering all orders on
time no delays they want to get your
product
and they want to get it to you quickly
as possible like i said these these are
time pieces that you're going to enjoy
wearing
every single day you'll be proud of
wearing them if you don't ventura will
make it right
that's their promise if you don't love
it they'll make it right by you go shop
ventura
the deal really is too good to pass up
go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com forward slash walsh do
not pay
full price on these beautiful timepieces
take advantage of our exclusive discount
and get up to twenty percent off your
entire order right now for
cherrywatches.com
all right well the problem with calling
anyone racist these days of course
is that the world you know the word is
like a blank space in a mad lib
fill it in however you like it can mean
whatever you want it to mean
this is by design of course it's easier
to weaponize the racism label if you
don't have to worry about using the
label correctly
that's what makes the latest publicity
stunt from yelp so disturbing
now yelp has long been hated by some
small business owners who complain that
negative reviews on the site can have a
significant impact on their business
despite being potentially inaccurate or
malicious
a recent documentary actually called
billion dollar bully
claims that yelp essentially extorts
smaller companies
demanding that they they buy advertising
in exchange for minimizing negative
reviews that's what the
documentary claims yelp denies this
charge and even
bought the billion bully.com domain name
and redirected it to a page on its own
site clarifying
or claiming anyway that it does not
extort small businesses now you could
judge for yourself whether buying the
domain name of a documentary that
accuses you of dishonest tactics
is itself a dishonest tactic
well we can say yelp's latest innovation
um which which which begs to be
exploited by bad actors
is an official business accused of
racist behavior alert
company explained the new system in a
series of tweets here's what they said
today we're announcing a new consumer
alert to stand against racism
the last few months we've seen that
there is a clear need to warn consumers
about businesses associated with
egregious racially charged actions
to help people make more informed
spending decisions communities have
always turned to yelp and reaction to
current events and our
user operations team already places
alerts on business on business pages
when we notice an unusual uptick in
reviews
that are based on what someone may have
seen in the news rather than on
first-hand experience
now when a business gains attention for
reports of racist conduct
yelp will place a new business accused
of racist behavior alert
on their yelp page to inform users along
with a link to a news article where they
can learn more
now the the alert um which you can see
here
this will pop up for any business under
suspicion of racism
says in big bold letters business
accused of racist behavior and then it
explains
recently someone associated with this
business was accused of racist behavior
resulting in an influx of people posting
to their
their views to this page racism is
reprehensible and has no place on yelp
and we unequivocally reject racism in
any form
read about the reports of racist
behavior here while we understand the
desire to warn others about racist
behavior associated with a business
all reviews on yelp must be must reflect
actual first-hand consumer experience
we have temporarily disabled the ability
to post here as we work to investigate
the content
what could go wrong businesses will be
tagged with the scarlet r
and then yelp will investigate to see if
the claims are actually
true how will yelp know if they're true
how will the business owner prove that a
supposedly racist thing
didn't happen or that a supposedly
racist statement
wasn't made classic case of guilty until
proven innocent and here there's no way
at all
you could possibly prove your innocence
keep in mind
that racism is not just a vague and
ambiguous word
these days but also according to black
lives matter and other proponents of
critical race theory
it's a word that applies to all white
people inherently by nature of their
whiteness
you know by this way of thinking any
action taken or words spoken by a white
business owner
is automatically racist at some level
because racism is embedded in the
structures of whiteness or some such
nonsense
it would seem that the only evidence
needed to prove a racism charge against
a business owner is that business
owner's skin
color but not to worry if you run a
small company
you've already been decimated by covid
lockdowns perhaps rioting mobs on top of
it
and are now worried about being labeled
a racist by a vindictive customer or
hate crime hoaxer
yelp has resources to help yelp has
partnered with a group called
open to all quote to bring local
businesses a new toolkit that allows
them to
take the next step in creating an
inclusive community the toolkit includes
a 60-minute unlearning bias training
video for employees
outreach language for customers and
employees social media assets and more
and for just ten dollars you can get a
sticker to put on your window that
declares your business
open to all which hopefully will
convince the woke mob
to spare you like the angel of death
passing over the homes of the israelites
with lamb
lambs blood smeared on their doors um
the open tall website
also has a number of videos that
illuminate the discrimination and racism
issue
including this one i'll show you here
which condemns businesses that require
biological males
to use the men's restroom watch this
i'm a transgender woman i was born and
raised as a boy but inside i always knew
i was female
so i transitioned and now i live every
day as the woman i've always known
myself to be
it can be hard to understand what it
means to be transgender especially if
you've never met a transgender person
in most states our laws don't protect
transgender people from discrimination
in public places
or when it comes to using the restroom
something we all need to do every day
i have lived as a woman for many years
most people when they stop and think
about it
they realize that when businesses can
legally force me to use the men's room
it puts me at risk for harassment and
violence
safety and privacy in bathrooms are
important for all of us
it's already illegal to enter a restroom
to harm someone
and anyone who does that can and should
be arrested
obtaining the law to protect gay and
transgender people from discrimination
won't change that but it would help to
ensure that people like me
aren't mistreated when we need to do
something as basic as using the restroom
if you're wondering whether yelp will be
judging racism and discrimination
complaints fairly
there's your answer this is the radical
leftist lens through which yelp like so
many other billion dollar corporations
views the world no surprise given that
this is the same company
which a few months ago unveiled a new
search option making it easier for users
to find and support
specifically black owned businesses this
is quite blatantly
racial segregation and discrimination
but it's the good kind according to the
far left
and potentially destroying innocent
business owners by
enabling libelers and slanderers to
smear them as racist without evidence
is also good if it advances the cultural
agenda
we can only hope that the first business
owner unfairly targeted
by the racism alert will be able to
afford a high priced attorney and can
sue yelp
into bankruptcy because based on this it
seems they certainly deserve
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well nancy pelosi had an announcement
yesterday
um here it is listen when we hear people
saying i'm
i'm young and i'm a perfect perfect
specimen instead of addressing the fact
that what 50 000 people were
in fact reported to be infected
yesterday nearly a thousand people died
what are we talking about here tomorrow
by the way
tomorrow come here tomorrow we're going
to be talking about the 25th amendment
but not to take attention away from the
subject we have now
yes uh the 25th amendments they'll be
talking about how to potentially remove
trump from office
with the 25th amendment now trump fired
back about this
uh here's the daily wire report it says
president donald trump and prominent
republicans fire back and speaker of the
house nancy pelosi thursday afternoon if
the speaker suggested that she and
democrats will hold discussions friday
about the 25th amendment presumably to
talk over how to potentially remove
the president from office retweeting a
supporter who suggested that democrats
were already plotting to get trump out
if the president
wins re-election november trump added
that crazy nancy should be evaluated for
her own mental
fitness crazy nancy is the one who
should be under observation
they don't call her crazy for nothing he
tweeted
pelosi announced her event at a weekly
press conference uh so you just heard
that
um later on thursday the hill reports
pelosi said
that she and representative jamie raskin
were planning to commission
quote to determine whether a president
is fit for office
raskin originally introduced legislation
2017
which should not get any legislative
action since republicans control the
house at the time
that would create an oversight
commission on presidential capacity
comprised of physicians psychiatrists
and retired public officials like former
presidents and cabinet secretaries
uh congressional leaders will be
responsible for naming members of the um
of the commission uh and then as far as
what this would actually entail like how
would you actually do this well pelosi
has an uphill battle according to the
25th amendment itself which governs
succession if the president's no longer
capable of discharging his duties
the vice president and either a majority
of cabinet members or a majority of both
houses of congress must agree
to depose the president before any
action can be taken to replace him so
um to summarize this of course isn't
really going to happen they aren't going
to depose the president
especially not a few weeks from the
election it's just not not going to
happen
though it wouldn't happen at any other
point either uh this is a political
stunt and a rather stupid one
from the democrats i would think there's
just no benefit
to them to do this all this can
potentially do
is fire up the right wing base
that's the only potential effect here
and and by the way that's that's what
donald trump needs to win the election
which of course is obvious of course it
needs his base but the point is you know
i
i don't think trump has done a whole lot
uh to appeal to
people in the middle and i don't think
he's done much there really
he's he's playing to his base all the
time exclusively
and uh which i don't think is the best
strategy but that's what he's doing
so if you're the democrats and you're
helping him mobilize the base not a
great not
not a great strategy there either so
that's why i say go for it nancy please
move forward
there's some conservatives that seem to
be upset or angry about this no do
go ahead this is great talk about the
25th amendment talk
talk openly about trying to depose the
president
you can't actually do it but if you want
to talk about it
please do number two here's a story that
i've been meaning to hit for a few days
but there's an update to it the story is
is that a school system in virginia was
going to adopt a speech code
banning their teachers from criticizing
in public
or private the school system's critical
race theory program
or it's or sorry excuse me it's racial
equity program is what we're calling it
now
uh so they weren't going to be allowed
to criticize it anywhere
on campus or off so here's the update
from the free beacon it says
the loudoun county virginia public
schools district will revise
a proposed speech policy which would
have prohibited teachers from
criticizing the district's racial equity
plan following backlash from the
teachers union and a washington free
beacon report
leadership from the loudon education
association the district's largest
teachers union
told the free beacon that a school board
member plans to take the speech policy
off of the upcoming board meeting
itinerary
effectively stalling any vote this
change will allow the human resources
department to revise and review the
policy that as currently
written prohibits employees from
criticizing the school district's
commitment to action-oriented equity
practices
in all forms of public and personal
communication
um and then it goes on from there okay
so
they're gonna revise and review revise
and review the policy
fine but even so the simple fact
that this policy was ever being
considered
the fact that this is what they want to
do
right it tells you everything you need
to know
and it shows i think it was a i think it
was rod dre who made this point about
this
particular story it shows again why you
know
you can't pin all your hopes on all your
hopes for the culture
on winning presidential elections
because every election
since i've since i was born every
election that i can that i was conscious
for that i can remember
uh you always had conservatives saying
we need to elect the republican or
america is over this is it this is the
last election
this is it every single election here
and we're hearing that now too
and every single time they say that
right but they say no no no this time
it's
it wasn't true before this i know i said
it before but this
this i'm telling you this time this is
the like if we don't win this election
it's over period
but then what happens sometimes
republicans are elected sometimes
they're not
and america's uh cultural march into an
insanity continues a pace
regardless it doesn't appear to matter
that much
culturally whether there's a republican
in office or not
in fact if i go back to 2016 before the
election
all of these dire predictions about what
the country would look like if hillary
clinton
was elected and i'm glad that she wasn't
and i do believe that it would look
worse if she was elected than than uh
than trump but
let's say you know 2016 before the
election
let's say someone from 2020 comes back
from the future and describes what
america looks like
and tells you about the rampaging mobs
and you know critical race theory in the
schools and
gender ideology going crazy just
describes what the culture looks like in
2020
and then says to you who do you think
won hillary or trump
you would probably say oh that means
hillary won i mean that's that's exactly
the america i expect if hillary wins
nope trump won now i don't um
i don't blame trump for that it's not
really a criticism of trump really
because there's nothing the president
can do about a lot of this stuff
i mean there's really nothing the
president could do for example about
decisions made by local school boards
so this is not an argument
that elections don't matter at all or
that you shouldn't vote or whatever
i'm simply pointing out that the real
fight the real fight for the culture
has almost nothing to do with national
elections
and that we as conservatives continue to
lose the culture
no matter who's in office
and so a certain point i think we need
to realize that we're not going to solve
the problem
just by electing republicans that that
doesn't even get close to it
and elect all the republican presidents
we want
but if we're still doing things like
sending our children into these schools
to be brainwashed for seven hours a day
it's not going to matter the culture's
lost anyway
how many of the republicans who are
saying oh we need we need a republican
in office or
how many of them are are willingly
sending their own children
into these government buildings to be
brainwashed into
things like critical race theory and
radical leftist gender ideology
you think trump is gonna you think
trump's gonna save your kid
when you're willingly subjecting your
child to that
at a certain point we have to be willing
to make difficult decisions do hard
things
beyond just voting for a republican
and we have to start thinking long term
also we have to realize that we're
we're not going to halt this march we're
not going to turn things around
i get this all the time when i go and i
say i was just yesterday i was speaking
at grove city college it was a great
event
uh and uh and i it and a lot of great
questions
but anytime i'm speaking i always get
this question like what do we do about
this
how do we solve the problem and i mean
it's it's a fine question it's a natural
question to ask but i think the answer
is
it's these are not problems we can solve
in a year or two years or five years
these are generational problems we're
going to solve this problem over the
course of generations
we have to accept the fact that you know
those of us alive today
we are probably not going to witness
much improvement
this is about our children and our
children's children
the left claimed the culture over the
course of generations they didn't do it
in
in a year okay they did it in 60 or 70
80 years
so that's what it's going to be for us
we have to be willing to accept that
okay
um this is supposed to be the headline
portion not me rambling on for
15 minutes number three joe biden was
asked about
court packing again and here's what he
had to say about that
don't know my opinion court packing when
the election is over now look
i know it's a great question y'all and i
don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline and every one of your
papers will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now the
election has begun
there's never been a court appointment
once an election begun but
four million or so people have already
voted
they're denying the american people the
one shot
they have under constitutional law to be
able to have their input
what a brave man what a brave brave man
isn't he always told he's such a brave
bold man
no this answer from him is nonsense and
by the way
his answer his answer about
court packing he says oh i don't want it
to be headline news well
it would only be headline news if he
would support
court packing if he's against it it
wouldn't get much play in the media at
all
so the fact that he's that he won't say
because he's worried that he'll make the
headlines
that's just him admitting that he's in
favor of quarterback number four the
number one song on itunes right now
is dreams by fleetwood mac
and no not like a remake or something
this this was uh or a cover or something
this was released
the original song released in 1977 is
the number one song on itunes right now
the reason it's number one is because of
a viral tick tock video
that incorporates this song
in the video the video apparently
massively viral very influential
enough to propel this song from from
1977 up the charts
uh so you're wondering what this what's
in this video it must be really really
amazing stuff well here it is
[Music]
yes that's the uh that's it that's the
viral video right there that's uh that's
millions of views on that thing that's a
guy drinking cranberry juice juice
while skateboarding okay
um you know there's a book out now
uh by ross do thought do that do thought
i never pronounced his name
new york times columnist conservative
and he wrote a book called uh
the decadent society which i'm reading
right now and i actually find it
i don't i don't read a lot of current
affairs books actually but this one i
find to be
pretty compelling and uh he makes the
case that we live in a decadent society
and he doesn't define decadent the way
most people think of it you know for him
a decadent society is one that's sort of
stagnant uh stale repeating itself kind
of running in place nothing's really
happening
we're just sort of coasting along and um
i think he's right about that
and he talks about how many many
a lot of evidence of this decadence a
lot of indicators of it and one of them
is in the area of cultural output and so
we bring up like people complain all the
time about all the remakes and
everything and
the number one movies are always like
star wars movies or star wars franchises
go back to the 1970s
and so you talked about that i was like
we're not even even
in in the area of pop culture and art
we're not coming up with new stuff we're
just recycling the old over and over and
over again
and um this would be a great example of
that
not just that this song from 1977 is
number one
but the reason for it is that because of
a video of a guy skateboarding while
drinking cranberry juice
all right now here though is a unique
movie here's this is something new
okay this is some cultural output we can
be proud of number five finally mel
gibson
set to start a movie where he plays a
down on his luck alcoholic santa claus
who's being hunted by a hitman who was
hired by a child who was angry
that he got a lump of coal for christmas
film sounds incredible it looks
incredible too here's a little bit of
the preview watch
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i've come for your hand fat man
you think you're the first
i think i got this job because i'm fat
and jolly
[Music]
oh come while you sleep the fat man's
got his eye on you
kids yeah i'm in i'm sold personally
you don't have to tell me twice some
people are upset about this because it's
mel gibson
and they're you know they're
automatically offended by anything mel
gibson does
but i'm sorry first of all mel gibson is
a great filmmaker and a great actor
uh he i love everybody he has yet to
direct a bad movie every movie he's
directed has been good
uh he's not directing this though but
and and most of
the films that he started have been
pretty good too as far as his personal
issues go
everybody in hollywood has shall we call
personal issues and males have been
more public than others perhaps but that
doesn't make it worse
than what other people have done i mean
roman polanski
child rapist is still making movies
so that's where the bar is set for
scumbag behavior
so yeah you can avoid mel gibson movies
because you find his personal behavior
abhorrent but
then you should also be avoiding a great
many films because a great many actors
and directors engage in behavior
far more abhorrent than anything mel
gibson
has been accused of doing that is a
movie though that i will be
watching all right let's get to our
daily cancellation
today i am cancelling all of the people
who are guilty of
mocking my lived experience and that of
my daughter
people on the internet who have said the
meanest things
things that have injured me down to the
very core of my being
what started this was a tweet that i
sent out um i should have known better i
suppose than to be so raw and honest
and bold and real on the internet that
doesn't mean that i deserve the
treatment that i receive let's not
victim blame
so here's what i tweeted this of course
is completely serious and meant to be
taken
absolutely literally this is what i
tweeted yesterday i said
during the debate last night my
six-year-old daughter turned to me in
tears and said daddy
that rude sexist man keeps interrupting
senator harris
this must be what misogyny looks like i
didn't know
how to respond we hugged each other and
cried
that's a true story i mean that really
happened the good news at least
is that a striking number of people took
this completely literally
and believed that i actually was making
this claim in all sincerity
and that's good because of course i was
it ended up also on a facebook page
called occupy democrats logic
a screenshot of the tweet and thousands
of comments there as well
many of them taking it seriously the
surprising thing is that is that
even some of the people who took it
seriously apparently knew who i was and
yet
still read this with no irony which
again is is the right
thing it's correct because i am never
sarcastic
i don't believe in sarcasm it's
extremely off-putting
uh and beneath me i certainly would not
be sarcastic about something like this
the last thing i would ever do is be
flippant or sarcastic about the problem
of sexism and misogyny
this is an issue that is deeply personal
to me and you know if you watch this
show that i have always been a
passionate advocate
for women's rights for women's rights
and equality
the problem is that many of these
comments from people who
took it seriously and their messages too
i got a lot of private messages a lot of
lot of hate mail um a lot of it was
quite vicious
the harassment and bullying has been out
of hand completely you know
i cried to my daughter about it for
hours last night
i cry pretty much every night in front
of my children i think it's important
for them to see
that their father is emotionally
unstable
i want them to know that they never have
to worry about toxic masculinity with me
because i don't have any kind of
masculinity
better safe than sorry i say now people
accuse me of being a bad father
some accused me of lying about this
story
some said that i am emasculated some
said that my six-year-old daughter
shouldn't be watching the debate at all
much less repeating feminist talking
points
in response to it uh one private message
called me get this
a sobbing eunuch someone else said that
i should have cps called on me
lots of people said that i'm filling my
child's head with lies and propaganda
my character was attacked my integrity
my parenting skills
but you know what i read many of these
comments to my daughter
and and my three-year-old son was also
there and actually
he made a great point i'll never forget
this this is what my three-year-old son
sean said to me he said father draw your
tears
do not be troubled for another man's
opinion
is irrelevant and ephemeral but i know
who you truly are
and nothing they say can change that and
i look back at him
tears again welling up in my eyes and i
said stop
mansplaining to me you sexist jerk
and i sent him to his room that's what
had to be done
and so he is cancelled and so is
everyone else who bullied me
though it will not stop me from speaking
my truth
and weeping uncontrollably
so we'll leave there i think on a on a
bit of an emotional and serious note
uh something for us all to think about
as we head into the weekend
thank you all for watching have a great
weekend godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there